Film Courage: So Alberto writes in “Can
the main character have two desires?”
Peter Russell, Screenwriter/Story Consultant:
Sure…but usually only one wound.
People often think…they get excited about
the core wound which they should because it
really gives you an original character.
And we in real life we have a dozen wounds,
right?
Let’s talk about mine or not.
But everybody has more than one wound.
But movies and to some extend television,
they are simple okay?
So you want to sort of see one big wound.
Big then many desires come out of that.
Tony Soprano had one big wound - my mommy
hates me.
But a bunch of desires came out of that - I
love bad girls, I love working at a club,
I love hurting people, I love to be mean,
I love to run things, I love being a boss,
I love being a dad.
So you can have many desires.
Just know that all of the desires come out
of the wound and they are often unhealthy
okay, that’s what we want to see.
If they were healthy, there would be no show.
Especially in television, you get wounded
and then you do a lot of unhealthy things
and sometimes your superpower and in television
that’s another thing you need to know.
Usually in television the hero has a superpower.
And usually that superpower (especially at
the beginning) can be used for wrong reasons
(bad purposes).
For instance, Don Draper in MADMEN has a superpower,
he’s insanely seductive.
And he’s seductive as a womanizer and he’s
seductive as an ad man.
But it comes from the fact that his mommy
didn’t love him, right?
He feels unloveable.
So all the things he does, he uses his superpower
for bad reasons because he’s wounded.
He seduces women, right?
He does ad campaigns for cigarettes and horrible
things and he’s immoral as an ad man because
he is misusing the superpower.
But the superpower came from his wound.
He he hadn’t been wounded (I’m not lovable)
he would never have become a great seducer,
he wouldn’t have needed to.
So the superpower is related to the wound.
But the things we wants come out of the unhealthy
desires of him trying to make the wound go
away.
Trying to feel better about the wound.
Every desire is an attempt to sopophorize
the wound, to palliate the wound.